Chimps,
I don't know if you know this or not,
but chimps basically go to war.
Uh,
Jane Goodall discovered that a couple of
decades ago and it really,
really was hard on her because she was
kind of a ruse soliah.
So for those of you don't know John,
John Jacques Rousseau is a French
philosopher and you know,
French philosophers have a lawful lot of
sins on their conscience and of course
we.
So it was certainly one of them because
Russell was the first,
like what fully articulate promoter of
the idea that human beings were
basically good.
So we know we had a good soul in a moral
sense,
but we were corrupted by our social
institutions,
you know,
so,
um,
you know,
as far as Russo was concerned,
it was kind of a noble savage idea,
you know,
like the human being in their raw form
has a pure soul and then you know,
you,
you give them to parents and you'd give
them to teachers and you know,
they'd get into politics and there's
group disputes and then they get all
corrupted,
you know,
and well,
that's,
I don't know even what to say about that
except that it's absolutely moronic
keynote,
but it's,
it's an appealing proposition if you're
naive optimist.
I mean,
first of all,
it doesn't explain where malevolence
comes from because the people created
the institution.
So,
you know,
it just puts you into an infinite
regress chicken and egg if the
institutions are reprehensible,
but the people who built them aren't
then where did the reprehensible
elements that the institutions come
from?
You know,
he might think it's an audio generating
consequences of organizing people.
But you know,
it's a pretty specious theory.
So I'm of course he had a counterpart of
philosophical counterpart,
Thomas Hobbs and Hobbs said basically
exactly the opposite,
that you know,
people were vicious and cruel unless you
like put them in straight jackets
fundamentally and made them obey.
Then everything was going to go
immediately to help you know,
when,
when you saw what happened in Iran after
the Americans walled stand in,
the power structure disintegrated.
Do you know what was a hell of a lot
more like than it was like Russell,
right?
You took out the tyrant at the top and
it wasn't like everybody got all
peaceful and loving.
All of a sudden it was like absolute
chaos reigned.
So you know,
of course you can rationalize that.
But anyways,
roost.
So by the way,
had five children by illiterate made
that that was as Mr.
and you put every single one of them in
orphanages where of course they perished
because orphanages have Russo's times.
We're not exactly,
you know,
a luxury resort.
And even up until the beginning of the
20th century,
most children who are under one years of
age who were in care institutions died
partly disease.
And that sort of thing,
but often because they just weren't
touched,
they weren't cared for physically.
Even if they were fed and you know,
200 years ago they weren't even fed
anyway,
so,
you know,
but nonetheless,
people have people
maintain the optimistic idea that human
beings were basically good and that they
were corrupted by institutions.
It's a common idea among.
I think it's a very common idea in
universities,
you know,
because university people are always
complaining about the corrupt nature of
this institution and that institution,
you know,
while they sit here in the warm with the
electricity on,
you know,
it's surrounded by wealth that
characterizes maybe one 10th of one
percent of the entire world's
population.
And you know,
they complained about how we'll press
they are and how will we know nasty the
institutions are.
It's like,
yeah,
well you actually haven't been to a
nasty institution,
you know,
cause nasty institutions.
They get pretty damn bad.
And most of the institutions in the
world are like that.
So it isn't exactly clear that people
are pristine in their heart and then
corrupted by institutions.
Although I'm sure that happens patent
depends around,
for example.
So anyways,
this has been a line of philosophical
speculation.
That's,
that's,
that's I would say constituted one of
the unspoken fundamental assumptions of,
of Western intellectuals in particular.
And Jane Goodall thought,
you know,
in many ways the same way she thought
chimps were basically,
you know,
they're just animals.
They are okay.
They exist,
coexist relatively peacefully with one
another,
you know,
even,
um,
Carl Rogers,
who I talk about a bit in my personality
class,
you know,
he basically thought that people are
fundamentally good and that institutions
make them bad.
But,
uh,
the problem is you look at chimps and
narrow a fair bit like us,
you know,
Bonobos,
you can look at them too,
and they're,
they're genetically quite related to us
and they're quite a bit different than
chimps,
but.
So we're sort of a weird mixture of the
two in some sense.
But Champs,
like those things,
there is no evidence that they really
have any internal control over their
regression at all.
You know,
there was a horrible case about two
years ago where a woman was interacting
with the chimp and it tore her to pieces
and they can do that.
Man took her face right off and they
have the strength of about six men,
like an,
an,
uh,
an adult.
Male chimp can break a 300 pound test
cable,
you know,
those things are really,
really strong and they are not friendly,
you know,
like.
So in Arnhem Zoo for example,
there's been a troop of chimps there
that have been followed by an extremely
brilliant apartment hall and just named
Frans de Waal who's work I would very
highly recommend.
The Wall is a very smart guy and he's
looked at the origins of morality and
chimpanzees,
you know,
from a biological perspective,
it's very,
very nice work.
Very,
very clearheaded.
But you know,
he's recounted absolutely horrific
stories of chimpanzee behavior.
So one of the stories he talked about,
for example,
was,
you know,
when you kind of have this idea that
there's a mail chimp hierarchy,
it's roughly true.
There's a female hierarchy too,
but the males and the chimp world
anyways tend to be the dominant ones and
you know,
you kind of think of a dominant primate
like a prize fighter,
you know,
pretty much he's ruling because of his
physical prowess.
Now that turns out not to exactly be
true,
but in this particular case,
the guy who was running the chimp troop
was a bit of a bully and he wasn't very
good at making friends.
You know,
and that's not such a good idea because
no matter how tough you are by yourself
to weaker guys can probably take you
out.
And that's what happened during friends
to was observations and two chimps
attack the leader and they had a
coalition.
They were grooming each other.
They repels,
you know,
in chimps are pretty good at remembering
like risk reciprocal relationships and
having friendships really.
Like they have a very highly social
structure.
Hey,
just tore him apart.
Like the things they did to him like you
don't even want to talk about.
And so chimps have really no upper limit
on their capacity for aggression and
when they hunt.
Because chimps,
Honda and they liked me,
they often call us monkeys and they
weigh about 35 pounds,
like a cola.
This monkeys a major league animal,
and they eat those things alive and they
scream while they're being killed and
that does not slow the chimps down one
bit.
So it's not obvious that the chimp is
really a creature of a lot of empathy,
especially the males.
The females are likely more empathic
because they have to deal with infants
for longer periods of time.
What seems to inhibit the aggression of
mail chimp's isn't anything they hold
internally.
It seems that when they get hyper
aggressive in the truth,
the truth gets more and more agitated
and basically shuts them down.
So you can imagine maybe you're in a
rough bar and some Dingbat who was,
you know,
half psychopathic and has had two pints
of alcohol is starting to cause a
tremendous amount of trouble and he's
not going to shut himself down,
but the rest of the truth might.
And that kind of means that the control
over the aggression is externalized.
It's not a consequence of super ego
control.
And we like to think that we actually
control our own aggression,
but I'm not so sure about that.
You know,
if you read things like there's a great
book,
Horrifying Book published about 20 years
ago called the rape of Nanking,
which is while the woman who wrote it
committed suicide.
So that sort of suffices to tell you
what the rape of Nanking is about.
And it's a story about the Japanese in
World War II going into a Chinese kid
city called Nan King where I believe
about 350,000
people were killed.
And the Nazis in that story where the
good guys.
So you can imagine the kind of brutality
that might be occurring there.
But there's absolutely perfectly well
documented evidence suggesting that the
Japanese soldiers engaged in competitive
brutality.
You know.
And so really what happened was the
Japanese had been pretty militarized by
World War Two and native adopted a
Prussian education system and the
Russians and Germans,
you know,
pre,
Pre 20th century Germans,
they were basically interested in
educating obedient soldiers,
you know,
because it was a militaristic culture
and the Japanese kind of adopted that
because they were sick of being kicked
around by the Europeans and pretty
successfully because they defeated the
Russians,
you know,
in the early stages of Roe or of the
20th century.
It was quite a shock to everyone in
Europe and,
you know,
cause for great celebration in Japan and
no wonder.
But anyways,
they militarize the hell out of their
young men and taught them basically that
the Japanese were a master race,
you know,
and that other people were sub humans.
It's a very common human way of
thinking,
by the way.
I would say it's really the default way
that human tribes think about other
tribes.
You what?
I mean,
it's a little more complicated than that
because human tribes tend to trade with
other tribes.
So it's not all demonization,
but a lot of it is,
you know,
and if you look around the world in the
anthropological literature,
what you see is that the names that most
tribes have for themselves is something
like that,
human beings or the people you know,
indicating that the rest of the people
are reading people,
God only leader,
barbarians or you know,
they live out where the sun is being
eaten by the dragon of the night or
something like that.
And you know,
the word barbarian is a,
is a word that comes from the Greeks
making fun of how non-greek spoke.
Know they thought they were bar bar,
Bar,
something like that.
So anyways,
what goodall phone was the chimps,
the chimp,
adolescence in particular in particular,
the males would patrol the borders of
their territory,
uh,
in groups of three or four and with
often with a female or two.
But the females didn't seem to be really
the,
they weren't,
they were more part of the group rather
than the initiators.
But what the chimps would do is if they
found a chimp from another troop,
even if that was a chimp that had moved
from their troop in the not too distant
past and joined another,
because sometimes the males leave and
sometimes they go to other troops.
If they are numbered them,
they would tear them to pieces and it
looked like that's why they were doing
the border patrol.
They're out looking for trouble there.
Gangs roughly speaking,
they're looking for trouble.
But the point of it is is that,
and they would only attack if they have
numbers because chimps can.
I wouldn't say they count,
but they have a rudimentary notion of
group size.
You know,
I don't think you can count without
being able to verbalize,
but you can estimate at a glance.
And so,
you know,
when I mean,
when I say tear apart,
that's exactly what I mean.
There's no upper limit on the brutality.
And so good all discovered that first.
And she didn't tell anybody above it.
Now she had a reasons.
I mean some of them I think radiological
or the lovely chimps,
you know,
and fair enough.
But some of it was also she thought that
maybe the chimps had been corrupted as a
consequence of their contact with human
beings and that their natural behavior
had been somehow transform,
you know,
and that's not,
it's reasonable to be cautious if you're
a scientist before you go out and say,
hey,
chimps go to war.
Isn't that revolutionary?
Because it is,
right?
Because it just,
it just ends.
The idea that our war,
like and malevolent nature is a function
of culture.
Like if chimps do it well,
what are they perverted by their own
culture?
I don't think so.
You know,
I mean there are more and less violent
chimp cultures and there are more and
less violent baboons culture.
So there was some cultural variation,
but since goodall's time,
this sort of behavior is being
documented on many,
many chimp truths.
So that's us in a nutshell.